what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video i'm going to make you guys an
expert on the green goblin norman
osborne because he's going to be in
spider-man 3 so why not go ahead and get
this out of the way now now here's the
thing this discussion is going to be on
norman so by and large we are going to
leave out harry osborne unless what it
is that harry happens to be doing is
pertinent to our discussion about norman
so norman osborne first appeared in
amazing spider-man issue number 14 in
1964 and he was created by stan lee and
steve ditko again stanley and jack kirby
were the ones who created really most of
the iconic superheroes that you're aware
of in marvel comics but stanley and
steve ditko were the masterminds behind
spider-man and pretty much all the early
villains and characters that you know
when it comes to his characters even the
main stays now right are basically all
just stan lee steve ditko creations by
and large the appearances of norman
osborn between issues 14 and 23 were
really just him kind of appearing in the
background or something like that but
never really doing anything major or
significant now the idea of him
appearing in issue number 23 was
actually based on a whole movie theater
concept that for whatever reason that we
didn't fully understand at the time and
actually wouldn't understand for some
number of issues later the green goblin
had it out for peter parker and so the
way this worked out was that operating
behind the scenes the green goblin
basically got the works or got things in
motion to create a movie about
spider-man and then spider-man was
invited to be in the movie this led to
the green goblin attacking spider-man
initially under the auspices that it
would be quote-unquote part of the movie
when the intention was to actually kill
him the other part was to get peter
parker to kind of lower his defenses
right now again at that point in time
norman didn't know that peter parker was
spider-man instead it was just the two
of them fighting now of course uh peter
parker gets the upper hand on norman
osborne and norman osborne is ultimately
defeated and that's where things get a
little bit interesting because when you
get into the actual origin of norman
osborn it's scattered all over the damn
place the origin of norman osborne is
found in three locations the first one
is spectacular spider-man annual number
14. the second is untold tales of
spider-man number eight and the third is
amazing spider-man number 40 probably
one of the most iconic spider-man issues
and we'll talk about why as we get
closer to it but with the spectacular
spider-man annual and with untold tales
what you basically learn here is that
between these two stories giving us this
explanation that norman osborne's father
was exceedingly abusive but became
abusive after turning to alcohol and the
reason why is that the osborne family
had a massive fortune that they had
amassed since really the late 1800s but
norman osborne's father had basically
invested the entirety of the family
fortune in an invention that he was
working on now we're not given the
details of it in fact as far as i'm
aware we don't know anything about it
all we know is the invention was stolen
and with it basically went pretty much
the entirety of the osborne fortune and
so after turning to alcohol he became
verbally abusive to his son and
physically abusive to his wife now
ultimately the mother of norman osborne
dies and when that happens his father
becomes even more abusive and actually
starts sinking further into a depression
but one of the things that had happened
is norman osborne's father had actually
locked him in the abandoned osborne
mansion overnight in an effort to kind
of toughen him up right technically in
the comic it was referred to as facing
the darkness but basically one of the
ways that norman osborne was depicted as
a little kid is that he was kind of weak
right that he was a little bit of a
weakling of sorts now really his almost
psychotic sociopathic behavior towards
humanity was rooted in his father's
belief that in reality the only person
in this world that matters is yourself
and and basically acquiring as much
wealth as you can is the only thing that
really matters and so in the aftermath
of this and with norman having being
locked in that mansion that he kind of
begins this process of basically
becoming the green goblin right in the
sense that like this kind of darkness
inside of him is sort of laughing
cackling in the distance that kind of a
thing that's what kind of sets the early
stages for the green goblin mythos now
the reality and the reason why that
happened is because by the time this
story was written you're already in the
mid-1990s and so coming off the stories
of like bill mantlow and peter david
when it came to the incredible hulk the
idea of building this entire philosophy
around the abusive nature of a father
and even more so than that the early
beginnings of a villain becoming a
villain kind of having a psychotic break
really taking place in their childhood
was huge because that was the entire
philosophy of the incredible hulk right
that bruce banner was being abused by
his father brian and that the idea of
him becoming the incredible hulk when he
was exposed to the gamma bomb that was
already on its way something would have
happened somewhere along the line that
led to banner becoming the hulk in this
instance it just happened to be the
gamma bomb and the hulk is a
manifestation at least in the early days
of all the rage he felt towards his
father and that's where the whole green
goblin mythos kind of tied into the
nature of norman now by the time you get
to the conclusion of spider-man annual
number 14 one of the things you learn
here is that uh because of the fact that
he was constantly ignored by his father
and the frustration that came with it
when norman osborne had learned of a
formula that was being developed by
wendell strom that would basically
enhance people so kind of wendell
strom's attempt to basically bring back
the super soldier serum that harry
osborne when norman was experimenting
with it harry osborne had actually
switched chemicals and so there came a
point when norman osborne went to
conduct his experiment and everything
went sideways and in fact the formula
actually exploded in his face and
started him down the process of bringing
out all the insanity that he'd basically
kept hidden but it kind of been
manifesting and growing ever since his
childhood now once you get into untold
tales of spider-man number eight one of
the things you actually find out is that
before norman osborne officially became
the green goblin he tried to kill peter
parker and the way this worked is that
he had basically orchestrated things
behind the scenes so that a movie would
be made on the life of spider-man and
spider-man would be brought in to of
course play the role of himself now
norman working behind the scenes had
actually sent in a couple of villains by
the name of hezman and scorcher to try
to take out peter parker of course it
didn't work and so in response to this
failure norman adopted the philosophy of
saying if he wanted to have anything
done he had to do it himself and that's
when he started working on the mock-ups
of the green goblin all this goes into
amazing spider-man issue number 14
despite the fact that spectacular
spider-man annual 14 and until tales
spider-man number 8 were written like 20
years after this right they were written
20 years after amazing spider-man number
40. but amazing spider-man number 40 was
a hugely significant comic nobody knew
who he was the readers didn't know who
he was nobody in the comics knew who the
green goblin was peter parker didn't
know who the green goblin was and in
fact there was actually a big fight
between stan lee and steve ditko over
how this was going to play out stan lee
wanted the green goblin to be norman
osborne steve ditko didn't and the
reason why is because in steve ditko's
mind things wouldn't just work out that
way where it turned out that the green
goblin was somebody that peter parker
had always known right it wouldn't just
kind of be that happenstancey like of a
situation but in the mind of stan lee it
fit in perfect because it would give a
kind of dramatic appeal that you really
wouldn't be able to get otherwise steve
ditko wanted to just be some swing and
dick off the streets that's really all
he wanted to be right just some random
person that we'd never seen before but
because of the fact that stan lee
usually always focused on the nature of
interpersonal relationships in the early
days of the comics but again norman
osborne being the green goblin would
have far more of an impact on the reader
than just some random guy and because
stan lee was the editor at least
according to his interview with
comicbook.com back in uh back in 2017
his response was i'm gonna be the one to
do this right it's going my way
and so ultimately ended up being norman
osborne who was the green goblin and all
this was revealed in amazing spider-man
number 40. now the way this worked is
that norman oswald had actually
developed a kind of substance that
basically took out the spider sense of
peter parker so green goblin could
follow him and then basically learned
that peter parker was spider-man and in
doing so kidnapped him and one of the
things you learn here is that the whole
reason why norman osborne as the green
goblin went after spider-man in the
first place is because in the aftermath
of everything that had happened with his
father losing his fortune and all that
kind of stuff and basically norman going
insane his desire was to rule the
criminal underworld but he couldn't just
walk in and say i'm norman osborn i'm a
great huge corporate guy yeah i have way
more money than like the kingpin does i
want to run the criminal underworld he
had to do something to prove his worth
and in his mind the best way to prove
his worth as being the guy that's
capable of running the criminal
underworld is to kill spider-man and
that's why he always chased him that's
why he always went after him now
ultimately in an effort to prove his
superiority he basically allowed
spider-man to escape right saying like
you're getting out of here with your
life because i'm allowing it
and peter parker ended up defeating uh
norman osborne anyway but during that
battle norman osborne was thrown into a
whole bunch of high voltage wires and
ended up basically falling into a state
of amnesia and essentially forgetting
that he was ever the green goblin in the
first place which was really a way it
seemed for marvel to kind of introduce
green goblin issue number 23 and just
basically kind of have him run as a
character for about 17 issues and then
close it out now there's a couple
reasons why at least i would kind of
surmise there's a couple reasons why for
why it happened this way i don't really
have any definitive answers i have
searched high and low
harry osborne didn't become the green
goblin until amazing spider-man 136 so
it's not as though it was an interim
period where norman stopped being the
goblin and harry took over instead that
didn't happen until much much later and
so we can largely surmise a few things
the first is that it was a test bet it
was designed to ask the question do fans
really care about the green goblin right
if we end it here we basically write it
out norman osborne doesn't remember
being the green goblin that part of his
memory is gone he's forgotten everything
after his son had basically gone to high
school and he kind of has to be
rehabilitated peter parker basically
burns the the green goblin costume are
fans going to write in in the letter
pages and demand more green goblin stuff
or are we never going to hear any
requests about this guy because a green
goblin didn't come back until about 56
issues later and so because of that
whatever the reason happens to be that
green goblin was basically gone when he
did come back in uh in issue number 96
that things were changed a little bit
now it wasn't as though some new writer
had taken over and totally reworked the
entire green goblin mythos it didn't
really happen that way instead this was
written by stan lee amazing spider-man
issues 96-98 stan lee brought him back
and then actually had the green goblin
and norman osborne operating as a kind
of multiple personality disorder sort of
thing where green goblin was actually
his own character in the mind of norman
osborne and so there were times when
norman osborn would be his normal self
and then switch over to the green goblin
and the green goblin would be in control
and then go forward and do his own thing
now there were some questionable things
that happened
during this point in time you end up
learning for example that norman osborne
was in an affair with gwen stacy which
is probably one of the most reviled
changes of the spider-man mythos you
know depending on what spider-man fan
you talk about when i when i say
depending on what spider-man fan you're
talking to precious few spider-man fans
will say that they thought this was a
good choice by marvel but the whole
story of the green goblin really seemed
to come to a head in amazing spider-man
issues number 121 and 122 when norman
osborne the green goblin was basically
killed essentially by peter parker now
this story is probably one of the most
significant stories ever published in
the history of marvel comics and even
comic books in general because this
story focused on the night when stacey
died and this was a big deal because at
this point in time and really up to this
point in time this never happened right
i mean this was written in 1971 and this
was a story where gwen stacy was
basically killed off by the green goblin
or spider-man kill gwen stacy himself
right it's one of those things you guys
know the whole story or you've seen some
variation of the story gwen stacy was at
the bridge and peter parker and
spider-man went there to save her and
then she was knocked off the bridge by
the green goblin and then peter parker
shot his webbing into her foot and her
neck cracks and then the green goblin
says she was already dead before you got
here so different things along those
lines right so it's one of those things
where it's kind of interpretive and i
don't even think jerry conway the guy
who wrote it came out and said one way
or the other but regardless of the
situation the fact that gwen stacy died
had two major impacts on spider-man the
first is that given all the rage and
anger he had towards the green goblin
both because of the previous conflicts
they had the lengths the green goblin
had went to to turn peter parker's life
upside down as well as the fact that the
green goblin in the eyes of peter parker
had killed gwen stacy or created the
circumstances under which gwen stacy was
killed peter parker lashed out and
basically the green goblin died in the
process up to this point in time in just
comic books as a whole not even marvel
comics but in comic books as a whole
there had never really been an instance
where a superhero had failed so
disastrously that their love interest
died that didn't happen that that never
happened right we've talked about that
before that like lois lane could get
knocked off the top of the building and
she could be a hundred feet from hitting
a ground or an inch it didn't matter but
superman would always swoop in and save
her in the nick of time gwen stacy dying
was landmark because it also taught
peter he couldn't be reckless right he
couldn't go into situations where a
member or anybody out there was in
danger and be reckless with how he shot
his webbing and kind of be distracted
and things like that he had to be hyper
focused and so as a result of that the
the really the death of norman osborne
this really just like i mean this is one
of those few instances marvel says you
know we're gonna it's gonna shake the
comic book landscape to its core never
believe marvel comics when they tell you
that in this day and age but back then
it actually did
this shook the entire comic book
landscape in ways that were never
thought possible because after this
things like iris west in the flash
comics at dc she was killed by reverse
flash this set the stage for the dark
knight returns for batman being dark and
brutal it really changed and introduced
in a lot of ways the possibility that
comic books themselves could just become
darker and more brutal because it just
opened a door that had just never really
been opened before now of course again
in the aftermath of this harry osborne
took vengeance against peter parker and
harry osborne ended up becoming the
green goblin basically taking up his
father's mantle instead which really
continues on into a full-blown
discussion about harry himself but as
for norman osborne himself his return
came in a couple different forms the
first real official return of norman
osborne was during todd mcfarlane's
spider-man run at its conclusion with
spider-man issue number 75 but the
return of osborne prior to his return in
spider-man 75 was actually covered
during the osborne journals or at least
osborne journal number one in 1996 and
what you end up learning here is that
the entire events of the cone saga right
so the idea of like ben reilly kane
peter parker this whole thing with miles
warren the jackal the idea that peter
parker might actually be the clone and
ben reilly or kane might be the actual
peter parker that all of that was
basically spearheaded by norman osborne
who had returned due to the regenerative
healing abilities that he gained by the
same formula that made him into the
green goblin and so operating behind the
scenes the whole point of norman osborne
as far as his role in the clone saga was
to basically drive peter parker in sync
to convince peter parker that he was an
actual clone and to remove him from the
entire landscape the hope was to use ben
reilly or kane as basically a spider-man
that would operate on behalf of norman
osborne while he operated behind the
scenes but all this came to a head of
course when the clone saga basically
ended and the norman osborne revealing
himself in issue number 75 basically
established that he was the mastermind
behind the clone saga he's the whole
reason why the whole thing happened in
the first place now the truth about this
is that the return of norman osborne for
a lot of spider-man fans was cool if you
go back and you read the old letters
pages that were being sent in fans were
happy to see norman osborne return he
was a character that people felt like
had been missing from marvel comics for
a long long time and the fact that he
was missing just kind of left a gaping
hole in the spider-man mythos but fans
were pissed about how he came back
they were like like clone saga sucked
and you're gonna use this to bring back
norman osborne
so fans were kind of pissed off about it
but at the end of the day their anger
towards the clone saga subsided as anger
towards pretty much any comic book story
does and people were just happy to have
norman osborne back but with norman
osborne back on the scene there were a
few things that happened right off the
bat right one of the things he did was
he bought out the daily bugle different
things along those lines trying to
basically discredit or really embarrass
jay jonah jameson use the daily bugle as
a way to kind of discredit spider-man to
extreme degrees and the way that that j
jonah jameson just didn't really seem to
have the heart to do himself the reality
though is that the the real brunt of
norman osborne returning took place in a
bunch of different issues the first one
was peter parker spider-man which was
really just a continuation of what uh
todd mcfarlane had done of course that
part of the story taking place in issues
44 through 45 running all the way up to
amazing spider-man issue number 441 and
even if we want to
509-514 but the important thing here is
that over the course of these various
stories a lot happened right a whole ton
of stuff happened so one of the first
things to take place is that norman
osborne basically tries to force
spider-man to become his replacement he
drugs him he puts the green goblin
costume on him that he actually ends up
orchestrating situations where peter
parker's friends are being attacked all
for the purpose of basically
brainwashing peter into believing that
he is actually the green goblin it
doesn't work right and a fight breaks
out and things just kind of go nuts and
then peter parker's just like i don't
want to do this anymore declares a truce
uh during the pulse comics you actually
end up finding out that ben urich from
the daily bugle a lot of you guys might
remember him from the civil war
frontline comics that we did back in the
day but basically kind of a mainstay
reporter really one of the big names
when it comes to reporters in mobile
comics had actually ousted uh norman
osborne as the green goblin publicly and
that the green goblin actually killed a
reporter by the name of terry kidder now
one of the big things with this is that
the entire launch of this the entire
defense of norman osborne was that it
was a smear campaign right that they
were basically trying to make norman
osborne look like the green goblin for
the purpose of just trying to get rid of
him or get him out to get him out of the
picture whatever the case happened to be
but luke cage actually ended up
confronting norman osborne when norman
osborne had launched an attack against
jessica jones and spider-man with
jessica jones being pregnant with luke
cage's unborn kid and so the result of
this is that when luke cage confronted
osborne despite the defense that osborne
had mustered for himself he actually
ended up attacking luke cage in front of
the world right cameras and all in his
goblin mask on his goblin glider so that
defense was totally out the window
there was no way for norman osborn to to
argue that he was not the green goblin
because he had basically he might as
well have been walking around with giant
purple letters on his head saying i'm
the green goblin right like that's
basically what his actions amounted to
and all this basically goes into really
the the events of civil war running all
the way up into dark rain and the reason
why this matters is because one of the
events that took place during this point
in time and one of the big issues marvel
had to contend with was joke assad
taking over as editor-in-chief and we've
talked about this before that quesada
believes spider-man being married
basically aged him he wanted to minimize
the idea that spider-man was older than
he actually was seemingly put peter
parker in a place where they could write
those kinds of stories for years and
years and years and years because if
spider-man gets married then that means
spider-man's gonna have kids and a
spider-man's gonna have kids that ages
him that makes him grow up and if
spider-man is having kids can he really
be a responsible superhero and have
children at the same time more so than
that new generations of fans are
probably going to want spider-man's kids
to become his replacement and so instead
of having to worry about all those
questions and answering even more
questions the idea of spider-man's
marriage to mary jane watson was
completely nullified as part of the
attempt of joe casada to really
consolidate and to restructure the
entirety of marvel comics and so this
was a pretty big deal because one of the
things that had happened in the
aftermath of this during the events of
spider-man one more day is that norman
osborne did not know peter parker's
identity right that's one of the things
that kind of happened as a result of
this is that it's really part of this as
well as part of uh spider-man uh one
moment in time as well as brand new day
kind of that trilogy is that that no one
remembered anything whether it was
because dr strange modified the minds of
everybody across all existence or
because mephisto had changed reality
himself between these stories nobody
knew that peter parker was actually
spider-man and so during this time as
part of the events going into civil war
what you actually had is the
thunderbolts right the formation and
really the newest iteration of the team
led by baron zemo and green goblin was
brought on as part of the thunderbolts
now the reality and really for anybody
who was reading civil war at the time
norman osborne seemed like a character
that didn't need to be on the
thunderbolts because he was bigger than
that and in a lot of ways it made sense
right the thunderbolts was kind of a
poor man's evil avengers team it's
really what it was right it's kind of a
cheap knock-off
and so because of that people were kind
of like this doesn't make any sense but
the point was not to put norman osborne
on the thunderbolts and leave him there
indefinitely the point was to put him on
the thunderbolts as a reason to one get
him out of jail and two get him into the
intelligence community the reason for
that is because going into the events of
secret invasion where the scrolls had
basically started replacing superheroes
and humanity government officials things
like that with scroll replacements in an
effort to conquer the world as a result
of galactus destroying the scroll home
world this led to norman osborne
actually intercepting information that
would basically lead to the defeat of
the scroll race during secret invasion
which he used now during this point in
time and in the aftermath of civil war
iron man was director of shield but
because secret invasion had happened it
had led the the the intelligence
community to question the ability of
iron man to be an effective leader if
shield serves the purpose of monitoring
earth for threats and iron man didn't
know that the scrolls were replacing
superheroes and people with scroll
replicants the result of this is that
and really one of the coolest stories
really one of the coolest publishing
initiatives that marvel had done this
led to iron man being removed as
director of shield and norman osborne
put in iron man's place as the new
director and this initiated what we call
dark rain dark rain was an amazing line
of comics god i love dark rain now it
was not a it was not a real story per se
it was not like you go when you read
dark rain you get dark brain parts one
two three four and five it doesn't work
that way instead the way this played out
is that with norman osborne as director
of shield because the superhuman
registration act was still in effect
meaning any superheroes that didn't
register with the federal government
were being hunted down by the government
itself specifically shield or at least
hammer as it was now called under
osborne most superheroes who were
already registered basically ended up
defecting right they basically went
underground and essentially joined
captain america's secret avengers those
individuals who had already refused to
register were already underground as
part of captain america's secret
avengers and so dark rain saw a huge
shift because one of the things that you
saw is that in the absence of
traditional superheroes that norman
osborne had actually started creating
dark versions of superheroes and so you
ended up having the dark avengers which
were basically villains playing the role
of the superheroes you had the dark
x-men which were villains playing the
role of the x-men because the x-men
themselves had actually left the united
states they had taken residents up on a
uh on an island off the coast of san
francisco that was quote unquote outside
the jurisdiction of the united states
and by extension norman osborne but for
osborne himself he ended up basically
taking up the iron man mantle and then
re-christening himself as the iron
patriot and then literally just
launching a campaign to basically
conquer the entirety of the united
states all under the guise of national
security right and so basically what
this did is it led to a really cool
situation where for the most part it was
just kind of like osborne himself the
green goblin kind of seemed to be out of
the picture but not really it was this
concept that was kind of lingering in
the background and you knew that it was
there but you didn't really see it as
like a major focal point the only real
time that you would see it crop up is
for example when the century robert
reynolds was being enlisted by uh by
norman osborne and norman osborne used
his history specifically his multiple
personality disorder aspect of the green
goblin to kind of empathize with robert
reynolds and to say i know where you're
coming from work with me and we'll find
a way to basically take care of this
right just things along those lines and
so all this basically led to norman
osborne creating things like the list
which was basically like literally a hit
list people that he wanted to have taken
out various threats and things like that
that were going to be eliminated and
then it all basically came to a head in
siege on asgard and siege on asgard is a
story that we have covered and it was
basically the whole idea that norman
osborne saw asgard in brockton oklahoma
as the last real holdout that if he was
able to conquer that he would in effect
have any real major threat to his
dominance over over the united states
completely eliminated now as we saw with
c john asgard that loki who would
actually join osborne turned against him
and then tried to find a way to help the
asgardians win only for the century
robert reynolds to lose his mind become
the void norman osborne lost control of
him the goblin personality started
coming back like literally it hit the
fan fast
everything that could go wrong for
norman osborne did and basically the
superheroes ended up winning norman
osborne was defeated and thrown in jail
when it was revealed that he had had
engaged like all these real criminal
elements in order to solidify his power
which he had actually successfully
managed to keep hidden from a lot of
government officials now the truth is
even the white house was getting uh
getting wind of what osborne was doing
but they would give him a little bit of
a leash because in the aftermath of
stanford the launch of the superhuman
registration act the superheroes need to
be curtailed and the the point that
osborne made is it takes a firm hand to
defeat a firm foe and the superheroes
have to be reeled in and i'll do
whatever i need to do so he was kind of
given that leniency siege on asgard was
going too far and that's why you ended
up seeing the federal government and
even the superheroes all turning against
osborne which is what led to his defeat
now following this there were a few
things that went on in avengers vol 4
but it was really more of marvel just
kind of doing cleanup duty in the
aftermath of dark rain right like norman
osborne escaping trying to reform hammer
ultimately being defeated and then being
thrown back in jail again and that kind
of a thing and that was really it right
things wrapped up pretty readily with
norman osborne and you saw a few stories
in the aftermath goblin army rise of the
red goblin different things like that
there was one point where he was trying
to get superior spider-man to work on
his behalf different things along those
lines but in truth a lot of this was
really just norman osborne kind of
operating behind the scenes especially
during goblin army trying to create an
army for himself using the forces of the
jackal different things along those
lines but the rise of the red goblin is
really where it became a lot more
interesting and the reason for this was
because at the end of the goblin army
peter parker had basically defeated
norman osborne by injecting him with a
serum that was basically a cure to the
goblin persona so it basically got rid
of the green goblin that's more or less
what seemed to happen and norman osborne
had gone back to having a life of sanity
now during rise of the red goblin he had
tried to bring back the goblin army but
none of it really seemed to work and
when he tried to re-inject himself with
the goblin formula that didn't work
either and so essentially he had lost
his ability to become the green goblin
which was now completely de-powered this
basically saw him turning to what was in
effect the carnage symbiote and then
basically becoming a version or at least
the newest version of carnage on top of
that when the green goblin persona
returned as a result of the carnage
symbiote then you basically had the
green goblin with the power of carnage
which was crazy because it was like
insanity times two
there was a really cool story we're not
gonna go super in depth into this
because we're actually gonna cover it
here on this channel as part of our uh
really continuation of of concluding
dance slot spider-man run which we never
actually did but it was a really really
good story it was an amazing story but
all that really spearheaded and really
segued into the events of absolute
carnage because norman osborne had been
in possession of a symbiote it had
basically left what we refer to as a
codex basically like a little piece of
the symbiote inside his genetic
structure and that carnage was traveling
around trying to gather all these
codexes for the purpose of making
himself more powerful to defeat null the
symbiote god the person responsible for
creating all the symbiotes as we covered
during the events of absolute carnage
that norman osborne is one of the people
who was defeated he was one of those
people who was overtaken by cletus
cassidy and the result of this is that
he was kind of conscripted into the
forces of cletus now in the aftermath of
that and with the absolute carnage event
basically wrapping up by and large you
actually ended up seeing norman osborne
fall to the background because in the
aftermath of absolute carnage it went
directly into the king in black which
was really a venom story right it was
really just the story of eddie brock
kind of again completing his redemption
arc fully becoming a good guy and quite
literally saving the universe so yeah
right now things are a little murky with
regards to norman osborn we don't really
know exactly what direction he's gonna
go in exactly what his character is
going to look like it's still kind of
unfolding and and sort of progressing
right so we're basically in the middle
of a story arc we don't really know
until it concludes but yeah i mean these
are kind of the broad strokes of norman
osborne right you're talking about a guy
who's been around since 1964. right this
guy's been around for a long long time
so about 58 years kind of hard to cram
everything about a character from 58
years into a single video but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace